I am trying to contribute to telling a
new story of us
that you know binds us together more
than it tears us apart and kind of gives
us something to build on together like
I'm not trying to take anything from
anybody I'm trying to create something
more with you that we couldn't do on our
own
and and we have we're now in this era
where telling the truth just being real
about American history is partisan is uh
described as hate speech loving is known
and if you don't know the dark stuff
you can't love the whole person and if
you only love them because they make you
feel good about you you're just using
so we scale that relationship concept
out to a country
we gotta love our country the way we
love our minds where we love our kids
the way we really love the people we
know and we cannot love a nation while
simultaneously refusing to fully know it